what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so Nightwing the new order is well
to be quite frank with you guys it's one
of the best comic book stories I've read
in a long time absolutely love this
whole thing because this gives us a
version of Nightwing that like we've
never really seen before well the cool
thing about this is that we initially
pick up really just with Dick Grayson
himself and the problem is or at least
what seems to have happened is that
somewhere along the line all the powers
have effectively been deactivated
everybody out there this got super power
center bikes by an extension of their
gene have effectively just been shut off
what we end up finding out here is that
Dick Grayson is the one that did this
that Dick Grayson had a device at his
disposal that he used that essentially
shut off the powers of almost every
single superhero on earth now the reason
why I say almost is because what we'll
actually find out is not every superhero
or super villain have lost their powers
but those individuals whose abilities
are directly tied into their genes
meaning that their cells are what allows
them to do the kind of things they do
they lose their powers so Superman comes
crashing down and is effectively mortal
he's just as vulnerable as any normal
human being and we end up finding out
that some massive battle seems to have
taken place in the city of Metropolis
some massive conflicts been going on
here and the result was that Dick
Grayson basically shut everybody's
powers down because he was simply tired
of it all now this is cool because at
this point we end up coming forward
about 12 years later
- Arthur light now Arthur light also
goes by the name of dr. light and as far
as I'm aware he's the original but dr.
light had the ability to basically
manipulate the light spectrum and he
could do it for a variety of different
effects and so because of this dr. light
is one of the more powerful beings out
there but as a person that seems to have
basically been able to maintain his
powers now the result is that in this
instance what this really seems to hit
at is that currently it's illegal to
have powers a person is not allowed to
have any super powers whatsoever and of
course once he subdued Arthur is
basically taken away and then we get
this sort of this this explanation
essentially that you know we're picking
up one in Gotham City in the year 2040
and to legislation has been passed that
is basically banned super powers the way
this whole thing works at least as is
explained by Dick Grayson is he's the
one that's basically taken the step to
kind of be the the figurehead of this
whole thing as it was really cool
because he's a lot of it you know very
much like a celebrity in that regard in
terms of how people view him but he's
kind of leading this group called the
Crusaders and the Crusaders quite
literally go out and they essentially
capture individuals who have powers
either their powers are newly emerging
or they
always maintain their powers and simply
just manage to escape any measure of you
know captivity or something along those
lines and so because that word Dick
Grayson shouldn't normally go into the
field he usually does if for no other
reason to kind of recapture the
excitement that he experienced back when
he was Nightwing back when he was you
know basically fighting alongside Batman
but at this point we transitioned back
to what really kind of seems like Wayne
Manor and it's kind of cool because what
you have here is basically Alfred
Pennyworth and Alfred's whole thing is
it's basically kind of play like a
father figure in a lot of ways to Dick
Grayson because at this point in the
story Batman is dead
not only that Dick Grayson has a son
this is kind of intriguing because what
they end up hitting at is the idea that
basically the wife of Dick Grayson had
essentially walked out does she had
basically walked away from the whole
thing
and Alfred kind of hints at it you know
he sort of asked the question hey looked
as Jake ever asked about her you know if
he does what answer do you give but in
truth
Nightwing really kind of tries to avoid
the whole discussion you know Dick
Grayson tries to walk away from it which
at that point it begins to shift to the
motivation as to whether or not it's the
right thing now this is important and
this is cool because when it comes to
Alfred he's always been that guy right
like Alfred has always been the voice
the conscience in the back of Bruce
Wayne's mind and with Bruce Wayne and
being out of the picture that kind of
follows on to Dick Grayson since he's
really the one this seems to seek out
the counsel of Alfred Pennyworth with
regards to various things and so it is
an interesting scenario because what we
end up finding out is that Dick Grayson
son was basically being bullied at
school but where he initially put on the
idea that well I mean you know just
being bullied because there's kids there
who were just kind of bullying we end up
finding out that this kid Chris Ramsey
that was bullying bullying Jake was
basically the nephew I think of Arthur
life so that's why he was really kind of
lashing out is because in his mind the
owe Dick Grayson is the one responsible
for putting his uncle in jail and if
Dick Grayson can't be attacked by Chris
Ramsey he'll do the next best thing
which is the son of Dick Grayson but it
is sort of sort of intriguing because
this is kind of like a moral debate here
that goes on between him and his son but
with regards to this it brings him a
whole idea of well hey look the world
was a bad place there was a rough place
and I as Dick Grayson fixed it by
removing the source of the problem which
was everybody who had superpowers and
when the questions asked do you regret
doing that do you ever wish that you
hadn't done that in the end he says no
because the good outweighed the bad but
that's the crazy thing about this
scenario is because what ends up
happening is Dick Grayson is called to
school and apparently the coaches the
hold only one who saw this happen and
when Dick Grayson shows up and he's
taken to the boys locker room what we
end up finding out is that jake has
powers and when you're Dick Grayson and
you're basically the face of this
institution that exists for the purpose
of rounding up anybody with powers and
then either throwing him in stasis
because you can't find a way to cure
them of their powers or else inoculating
them and removing their powers entirely
what do you do when one of those people
is your son and that's where everything
changes and that's why this story is so
cool because what we do is we kind of
jump back and we get this sort of
explanation with regards to everything
that was going on and what we have is
really this sort of discussion that it
all kind of really started with Superman
Superman was like the first hero to show
up on earth they kind of set off the
superhero Renaissance when Superman went
public and said hey I have powers and
I'm here to save metropolis
well then suddenly all these people
started stepping up now what this meant
was that it was only ever a matter of
time before something happened all we
know is that somewhere along the line
all these all these other super heroes
and super villains effectively went to
war with one another and the battles
were intense and the battles were
extreme now this is giving us this kind
of major conflict here but in truth what
it really says is there were a lot of
like small skirmishes and then some
massive war broke out and when this war
happened Dick Grayson sat down and said
enough Sanath and what he basically did
is he activated this device and shut
down the super powers of everybody on
earth or at least seemingly everybody on
earth but in response to this he
basically became a kind of celebrity
that people were like Dick Grayson is
the one who saved the world Dick Grayson
is the one who made and you know made
the world a better place and where he
kind of shied away from this initially
after a while he sort of began to revel
in it not only that as soon as this
legislation was passed that made it
illegal for anybody to have superpowers
people were desperate you know there
were various individuals who sided with
superheroes didn't have powers but they
were executing these campaigns where
they were trying to assassinate Dick
Grayson trying to take him out all these
things really came to a head whereby
eventually it was the formation of a
quote-unquote new order that served the
purpose of policing superpowers if
people have powers and no one knows how
to cure them they're thrown in stasis
individuals do have powers and these
powers can be deactivated they're shut
down now the way that this is done the
scientific side actually comes from
Michael Holt Michael Holt is a guy named
mr. terrific for those are guys who are
now familiar and mr. terrific is
effectively one of the smartest people
out there and we're
racin simply ask the question Theo
what's going on here is it possible to
neutralize my son's powers Michael Holt
says no like his your son has had these
powers for about a year he's basically
been hiding them from you yeah when the
question is asked by finding Greyson why
didn't you tell me Jake's response was
well you said people with superpowers
are bad and I didn't want you to think
that I was a bad person and it's kind of
heartbreaking because the funny thing
about this is Jake is a little kid he
looks at the world through the eyes of a
little kid all he knows is what he's
been told he just follows this kind of
linear progression if I tell my dad I
have superpowers
my dad will think I am bad it's simple
but that's how children think in a lot
of different ways and so because of that
this ultimately kind of culminates with
this whole discussion and you know
alongside Alfred Pennyworth and it's a
pretty big deal because Alfred kind of
hints at the idea that there's a more
sinister reason for why Batman was dead
but it's also cool because where Alfred
is a person who is pragmatic who's more
reasonable he sits down and looks at you
know looks at Jake and says look not
everybody who had superpowers was
inherently bad some of these people were
good but your dad believes it he's
probably doing the right thing the issue
with this is that really early in the
morning essentially all the alarms go
off and we basically have the Crusaders
invade the entirety of the house and
effectively have the intention of
grabbing Jay Grayson and taking him away
because of the fact that he's got powers
now Alfred does what Alfred always does
and basically says look you know I'm an
old man but like I'll whoop your ass
with the best of them Alfred doesn't
take any crap from anybody but of course
this plays out exactly as we would
expect
Alfred goes to attack one of the guys
with a baseball bat Alfred is shot and
killed now initially Jake's powers start
to flare up and it's sort of interesting
because we don't really see what he's
capable of right off the bat instead
he's immediately inoculated he's
basically knocked out and Dick Grayson
is taken away under the auspices that he
effectively Harbor the powers of a
super-powered person regardless of that
person's relation to Dick Grayson
himself and so at this point we switch
over to Washington DC and we pick up
with bat woman we'll find out more about
what's going on with her here in a
minute but you know she of course knows
exactly what's going on with Dick
Grayson and with Jay Grayson and
initially you know it's kind of like hey
look don't go in there don't interrogate
him don't talk to him don't look at him
do nothing until I get there now we're
one of the cops Brady takes this as kind
of a challenge of sorts where he sort of
looks at Dick Grayson as this guy's got
no powers and not to worry about this
guy the reason why Batwoman told him
that was not for the benefit of Dick
Grayson it was for the
of them it was it was for their own
safety because I mean let's be honest
guys this is Dick Grayson we're talking
about and so basically where he's
taunted a little bit considered to be
washed stuff considered to be an older
guy you know at the end of the day he
just picks his handcuffs and immediately
takes these guys out and then engineers
his own escape and it's cool and so what
we end up doing is having a Dick Grayson
travel over to the home of Tim Drake and
that's kind of cool because Tim Drake
has settled down he's walked away from
that whole life he's not Red Robin he's
got a wife he's got a couple of kids
he's basically enjoying the peace and
prosperity of his own life but this is
Tim Drake which means his intelligence
is just as good as it always was and so
what is up happening here is Dick
Grayson of course shows up and says I
need to know where my son's being held
now the other half of this is that it
kind of sends him on this journey of
sorts to basically go through and look
around and try to find these different
aspects of you know where these
individuals might be one of the first
place he heads is the Batcave and the
funny thing about this is that when
Bruce Wayne's identity was outed as
Batman following his death the Batcave
turned into a tourist attraction for
forty bucks you can go and tour the
Batcave the other half of this is that
there's the Batcave then there's like
the sub levels and the sub level sub
levels and the levels below that I mean
it's crazy you know how far though how
far the whole thing goes down and so
really the Batcave is known to people
only on the surface and so it's kind of
like this giant cave you go into and
you're - Ernie look at the computers and
you look at the batwing and he look at
the Batmobile and then you know you take
your pictures and then you go about your
business and that's really about it
but if you know the right places to
access if you know where to get into
then you know all the stuff that's there
what we end up finding out is a lot of
these things haven't changed a lot of
these things are still there the costume
of Nightwing is still there the various
devices and artifacts that Batman used
to use are still house down in that
sublevel at this point we end up picking
up with the whole idea of why Batwoman
harbor's is kind of vendetta against
Dick Grayson and what we end up finding
out is that of course she basically
works in Washington and in a lot of ways
she was the one that basically created
the whole organized system in terms of
like the Crusaders and the government
side and the you know the the kind of
paramilitary system as it functions now
but Dick Grayson was the one who took
everybody's powers down and so because
Dick Grayson was a celebrity
Dick Grayson was the one who was put in
charge of the program and so effectively
that woman built the whole thing and
then she was removed
as as head of the whole project and Dick
Grayson was put in her place and he just
kind of rode into the sunset with us
said yeah man I'll do it I got no
problem with that and that's where you
kind of run into this riff because where
Dick Grayson immediately takes off and
says okay first business that you know
first first order of business gotta find
my son he's immediately met by Jon
Stewart the Green Lantern and this is
cool because what we end up finding out
here is that Jon Stewart is working
alongside the other I guess working
alongside the federal government as part
of this whole group that exists out
there to just capture people now the
other half of this is that with regards
to Dick Grayson himself because of the
fact that he's so capable in terms of
his abilities and because Batman
designed a lot of these artifacts to
fight against superheroes should they
ever go rogue our dick Grayson's and in
possession of a set of gauntlets that
can basically pierce the hardlight
constructs of the Green Lantern and so
at the end of the day the powers of Jon
Stewart don't really amount to much the
problem with this is that this is Jon
Stewart Jon Stewart was a Marine Jon
Stewart is one of the best screen
lanterns out there anybody who manages
to outwit Jon Stewart doesn't do so for
long and that's exactly what happens to
Dick Grayson despite the fact that he is
pretty capable he is an older guy as are
the result is that Jon Stewart
ultimately ends up getting the upper
hand but where we would expect to see
Jon Stewart completely and totally
defeated Dick Grayson is whisked away
and we end up finding out him being
removed was done at the hands of
Starfire Corinne as well as the flash
Wally West and so is this this it's cool
man
that's why I say the story is so
interesting this story is wild in terms
of how all this unfolds now of course
moving back over to that woman it's
really very much a discussion that goes
on with regards to the whole thing of
like you know Jake and and you know her
talking about everything it is
interesting because the question that's
asked from Jake is are you going to
freeze me am I gonna be frozen am I
gonna be put in stasis because you don't
know how to shut my powers down you
don't know how to handle it now this of
course indicates that Jake is somewhat
aware of what's going on the other half
of this is that Batwoman is cold she's
really kind of like hardcore like hey
look there's gonna be a battery of tests
you're gonna be put through all
different kinds of tests and when you
are like you're gonna have to get some
rust and you're gonna have to toughen up
because some very hard times are ahead
for you but again switching back over to
Nightwing we basically end up having him
come to by extension query you know by
Starfire beast boy who's basically stuck
in this animal form because of the fact
that when his genes when his powers were
shut down
he didn't revert to his previous form he
was stuck in the form that he was in at
the time of course wally west has his
powers because remember this is one of
those instances where powers were
affected those individuals whose genes
allowed them to use various abilities
when it comes to wally west
he's not like made of the speedforce and
so it's only the speedforce irken is
confined within his genes instead it's
just a source of energy he taps into but
one of the more interesting things here
and this is something that I won't even
notice is that we have a blue lantern
here and this blue lantern is Lois Lane
we're not told how Lois Lane became a
Blue Lantern
we're just told that she is but the
problem with this is that neither of the
Titans themselves you know know we're
nowhere
Jake Jake Grayson is being held nor does
Nick himself as well this point is kind
of trying to figure out what in the
world is going on and how to access
those different things or at least how
to access his son the question that was
being asked by Dick Grayson for quite
some time is we don't have all the
superheroes where are they operating out
of what we end up finding out is they
were operating out of blood Haven the
one place Dick Grayson would never
expect those you guys don't know
blüdhaven is dick Grayson's own version
of Gotham City basically yes that's kind
of the whole thing that goes on there
but the other thing that this deals with
is the whole struggle between like Dick
Grayson and Starfire because what we end
up finding out as Starfire is the mother
of Jake you know she's the wife that did
Grayson married and the one who walked
away but a lot of this was because of
the fact that when it came to Dick
Grayson going on this crusade it really
turns starfire off to him because she
saw him as really more of like like a
dictator as it would effectively drew a
rift between the two of them and so of
course what we end up finding out is
they basically locate where it is that
Jake is being held and of course they
basically orchestrate an attempt to go
there and do essentially free hemp but
when they get in there they end up
finding out the entire facility is
basically being ran by mr. freeze or at
least it looks like mr. freeze it might
be kind of like a like a freeze robot or
something along those lines but the fact
remains here that what is up happening
is you know Victor freeze effectively
shoots these darts out they incapacitate
Wally West people turn to Lois Lane and
say look you've got a Blue Lantern me
you got to help us out but of course the
cool thing about this is Kyle Higgins
really grabs the existing Green Lantern
concepts as they were basically created
by Geoff Johns and says look the Blue
Lantern rings are not all-powerful on
their own the Blue Lantern rings
need to be in the company of a Green
Lantern ring in order to be able to
operate at their peak capacity and so
what is up happening is of course Lois
Lane is able to use her powers to
basically you know start orchestrating
their freedom but then Jay kind of
lashes out freaks out and then
sort of blows a hole and the whole thing
it allows the entire group to escape
which is cool because he basically
provides their out but hits the idea but
there's a kind of power here that he
possesses now most likely and what we'll
end up finding out is this is basically
the power of quarry that is essentially
you know it seems like the exact same
power Starfire the ability to kind of
manipulate you know solar energies and
different things like that but it is
gonna be kind of cool because what they
end up doing is going through and
basically start you know analyzing the
genes of Jake to see what Jake's capable
of to see what his powers are but what
they end up doing is basically
transitioning away from Bludhaven itself
and traveling to a new location
basically traveling to Metropolis and
when they get there well we end up
having all these forces who descend on
them you know these various gangs and
individuals like that we end up fighting
the group is met with the arrival of
Superman so again this is cool because
Superman's powerless
Clark Kent does not have any powers but
he's basically working alongside Lex
Luthor and this is cool because it's one
of those things worse like look the
enemy of my enemy is my friend you know
and in this moment right now where
Superman and Lex Luthor had been enemies
for years and years and years and years
the fact that they share a common enemy
in the form of this massive government
surveillance registration system means
they effectively kind of have to work
together now the other half of this is
we end up finding out the reason why the
attempts to shut down Jake's powers
weren't working was about because of the
fact that Jake's powers cannot
necessarily be deactivated but because
Jake's abilities are basically working
against the inoculation meaning Jake is
an effective you know effectively a cure
Jake is the the means by which Lex
Luthor if he's able to basically utilize
Jake correctly in terms of the powers
analyze them right and synthesize a cure
can basically start giving people their
powers back and it is kind of cool
because we end up having this
conversation that takes place between
Jake and Superman and what we end up
finding out is that the death of Batman
came at the hands of Superman that
Superman was basically under the control
of black kryptonite which kind of drove
him insane and in turn he essentially
totally obliterated Batman now this
seems to be the catalyst this seems to
be what set it all in motion the death
of Batman kind of sent Dick Grayson over
the edge and when you had all these
different conflicts that were breaking
out with all these superheroes Dick
Grayson looked around and said okay so
Superman was controlled by black
kryptonite and because he was so
powerful he totally obliterated Batman
and he was basically being controlled
you know who knows what he could do
this power he possesses and he's just
the tip of the iceberg so Dick Grayson
says the most pragmatic thing to do and
the most practical thing to do is to nip
it in the bud shut it all down
and he took everybody's powers away and
that was really about it and so where
this group is kind of working together
where Dick Grayson is really kind of
being held in stasis one ISM happening
is dick communicates with Batwoman and
essentially says look I've got a plan I
can give you what you want if you give
me what I want and so this means he
essentially betrays the entire group he
grabs his son and it says okay come on
we've got a safe place we're gonna get
out of here they essentially take off
when they do they're met by the arrival
of like Green Lantern they're met by the
arrival it looks like Captain Atom of
course there's also captain coal I mean
there's you know Red Tornado these
superheroes that we've seen in DC Comics
you know or even supervillains that
we've seen in DC Comics some of them
seem to have been militarized in the
sense of it's like okay look either
you're with us or against us if you're
against us you're going in the freezer
you're going in the meat locker but if
you're with us then you get your freedom
you get your autonomy and they basically
ended up choosing now again a lot of
this background we're not given to us
you know it's not really explained here
Dick Grayson basically says look the
entire group you want is in there me and
my son we're leaving we're going to a
Horn of the country and this is kind of
intriguing here and because for Dick
Grayson when he's basically leaving with
his son his son preserves this really
really compelling argument and that's
what that's one of the the core
components here the the price you pay
for being young is that in a lot of ways
you see the world for what it could be
not the way it is that's not a bad thing
because when you're kind of an adult and
you look around you say yep the world's
this way and you just kind of throw your
hands in the air and say along me you
know it's never gonna get any better
than this then of course it's not gonna
get any better than that but Humanity is
what changes his world humanities at the
top and that's the cases son presents
Dick Grayson kind of resistors argument
he says look you've seen videos you've
seen photos but you see it in hindsight
you weren't there you don't know what it
was like to wake up and fear every
single day and not know if today was
gonna be your last day you have no idea
what it's like to live in that kind of
fear but the response of Jake is to say
yeah but I mean Batman knew all that
stuff Batman knew how dark the world
could be he knew how screwed up the
world could be but Batman kept fighting
and the one thing that kept him from
going over the edge was you it was you
keeping him saying it was you being the
anchor that kept him from just falling
into the to the abyss
the of the ocean it was you being a
lifeline to always pull him back
whenever he straight away too far and I
always kind of wished I could be like
that I wish I could be like you when you
were Robin for Batman and as this is
huge this is the this is a huge thing
because it brings Dick Grayson back it
really kind of Yanks him back to the
reality of the situation but at the end
of the day sure there are people out
there who abuse their powers who's used
their powers for the various purposes
but Superman was a good guy
Wonder Woman was a good person Batman
was a good person you had more heroes
doing good things then you had villains
doing bad things and so at the end of
the day most people who develop their
powers they probably have some sort of
crisis or maybe they end up realizing
they can do bad things with them but
what it takes is guidance
it takes a helping hand to teach them
look you've got incredible abilities but
as we all know from the spider-man quote
with great power must come great
responsibility if you have the power to
fix things you have the responsibility
to fix things and so with that power
that you possess you have to do good
with it and so Dick Grayson effectively
turns the car around and good thing he
did too because the Teen Titans were
getting wrecked
they were basically on the verge of died
there was no possible way they were
gonna be able to pull this off but
because of the fact that Jake is the the
you know the the standard by which Lex
Luthor can effectively synthesize this
cure what is up happening is Lex Luthor
hooks Jake up to the Machine starts you
know is channeling this sort of you know
cure essence this energy of sorts into
Superman Superman regains his powers and
we're off to the races it's it's one of
the coolest things you know the guy pops
back up and says okay let's do this the
problem with this is that Lex Luthor
effectively has this kind of bomb that's
sitting under metropolis and where the
bomb will basically bring everybody's
powers back it'll destroy the entirety
of Metropolis in the you know in the
process now where Metropolis is kind of
a wasteland in a lot of ways on the
sense there there's a lot of buildings
that have been destroyed you know people
are still kind of experiencing the
fallout of the massive war between the
metahumans at the end of the day there
are still people who live there and this
is classic Superman this is classic
superhero storytelling if there are
people who live here and we can't get
them out of harm's way
then it's our responsibility to
neutralize the threat and that
Superman's idea everybody who has the
ability to help me out and lift this
giant chunk of land out into the
atmosphere then help me do this
everybody else go through and start
evacuating people and this whole thing
basically has the entire city of
Metropolis elevator at least as Giant
Bomb
elevated up into the air so that when it
goes off nobody's killed and effectively
this you know everybody's powers start
emerging again and so as a result we see
this kind of again Kingdom Come esque
situation in the sense that we're Kino
calm saw massive civil war among the
metahumans and the world was almost
destroyed this wasn't necessarily the
same thing but what it did do is it
started assuring in this sort of light
handed touch in the sense of the world
kind of looked around and said okay so
maybe Dick Grayson standard was pretty
heavy-handed to just shut down the
powers of everyone maybe that was pretty
extreme there are people out there who
were emerging with powers this should be
taught how to use those powers
effectively and so that's what ended up
happening what we ended up having having
de LAN here is that the entire concept
of all super powers being outlawed was
effectively lifted instead what they did
is they started putting in you know
essentially registration the idea that
people that had powers had to
effectively register their powers but it
was kind of a cool idea because at the
end of the day the entire idea began to
move in the direction of okay so like
for five years after this whole you know
the return of powers powers were still
illegal but once it was removed the
world started moving in the direction of
okay so like we're gonna have people who
are gonna start gaining powers there's
no possible way to stop that why not use
that to create a utopia why not use that
to find ways to make the world a better
place but again things wrap up pretty
fast you basically end up having a Jake
who basically gets married you know yeah
they have a kid of their own and it's
kind of leaving the world better for
them but again there's a lot of
storytelling that can be told here
there's a lot of background stuff that
can go on a lot of filling in the cracks
between what happened I mean I would
love to read a one-shot story about how
Louis Lane became a Blue Lantern I would
love to read a miniseries about how what
Superman was doing during this 12-year
period that landed him up to this point
DC if you are seeing this make those
stories for the love of God just call
them like new order pre ludes or new
order one shot so what everyone I call
it but write those stories for the love
of God please write those stories I
would love to see those things so much
blue that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain and make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]